esta será la jornada vacunación más
grande de la historia en el reino unido-
con una logística enorme y así se
acierta no se tiene certeza de cuando la
mayoría de la población está vacunada
hay nueve etapas la primera arrancará la
próxima semana para personas mayores de
80 años quienes estén en ancianatos y
sus cuidadores el reino unido ha
comprado hasta el momento 40 millones de
dosis de esta vacuna para 20 millones de
personas porque cada una necesita dos
dosis hasta el momento hay 50 hospitales
en todo el país listos para empezar a
poner estas vacunas pero se ha hablado
además de la necesidad de crear centros
especiales para poder estas vacunas
prácticamente en las 24 horas del día
siete días a la semana también se
establecerán puestos de vacunación en
centros comerciales en parqueaderos en
los médicos locales para lograr
rápidamente esta vacunación al celebrar
esta gran noticia para la ciencia
el primer ministro boris johnson
dijo que hay júbilo pero también les
pidió a los ciudadanos mantener la calma
y la prudencia porque el virus todavía
es letal y por ello el país aunque salió
ya de una segunda cuarentena se mantiene
en un sistema de alertas por zonas
prácticamente el país está en zona 2 o
zona 3 como aquí en londres en la que
prácticamente no se puede socializar con
personas con las que no se conviva sin
embargo hoy a partir de hoy están
abiertos nuevamente los locales de
comercio que no es esencial restaurantes
y hoy en las calles había muchísima
gente porque se siente este aire de
libertad el primer ministro boris
johnson también dijo que el reino unido
ha comprado 350 millones de dosis de 7
vacunas que están en desarrollo